hello everyone welcome to a little Day in
the Life what a new day as a non-diet [Music]
dietitian of course thank you so much to thrive
market for sponsoring this video I'm currently
on holiday in Florida with my family though
I am definitely still working so I thought
I would take you guys with me on a random
day of my Life as a mom as an entrepreneur
as a dietitian as a perfectly imperfect human
just trying my best to balance it all without
burning out also huge disclaimer that this is
my diet on a random day it is not meant to be
duplicated it is not meant to serve as some
kind of Instruction Manual of how you should
eat my needs are unique to myself and also will
change day-to-day just based on how I'm feeling
or what I'm doing so please speak to register
dietitian about your unique needs but first
coffee actually truth be told I've already had
a latte this morning plus some random leftover
bites from my kids breakfast it was a night last
night my kids were up about a million gazillion
times Carol and the morning ended with me
putting my 3 and 1/2-year-old in the car in
the pitch black trying to drive him around
the neighborhood trying to get him back to
sleep like literally haven't done that since
my first son had colic at 3 months so yeah if
I'm not forming sentences coherently today it's
because I haven't had a whole lot of sleep and
I'm also on like an ADHD medication vacation as
they call it though also my viance was kind of
causing my hair to thin and fall out so I DC
that and I still have not found a medication
that does the job for me it is a journey as
a lot of you guys know but the kids are out
of the house so I'm going to do a quick little
floor workout in the cramped space that I I have
just to get my body moving cuz I know that I'll
probably feel a lot more energized and a little
bit you know like I can start my day on a good
note if I get a little joyful movement let's do
it okay this is not Mom life I don't know what
is so I have a few essentials that I have here
in Florida um since we come here every year this
is not my usual gym I just try to get what I can
done and basically I use what I've got available
so I've got some little ankle weights I've got a
selection of bands here some of which my kids
have ripped because they like to do their own
floor workouts AKA they just like basically
try to shoot these and launch them at each
other and then I have some very light kind
of Weights ooh these ones feel heavy today
I guess that means I'm tired but you know
what I say any movement is good movement so
let's get her [Music] done okay not the most
intense workout but I feel better all right
now it is actually coffee time so let's get
caffeinated and make some breakfast so I got
a strange specific way I like my coffee I do
like 2/3 soy milk one3 unsed almond milk and
a little splash of this uh oat caramel Mach
macchiato creamer yeah it's really delicious
it doesn't have a ton of sweetness I do not
like sweet things it just has like a hint of
Flav flavor and it's got 1 G of added sugar
I got this at TH Market too all right let's
[Music] try
[Music] okay I was needing a fullon hunger
crushing combo this morning because lack of
sleep always always makes me hungry so I got my
water I got my protein berry smoothie situation
I got my L most important thing and okay here
in the States you guys have so many different
I don't know convenience breakfast options and
I'm seriously obsessed with breakfast sausages
so I got these turkey Maple breakfast sausages
they've got N9 g of protein in three which I
thought was pretty good and I love that you can
put them the microwave M it's so good okay so
we talk about my Hunger crush and combo a lot
on my channel and I know that is completely
revolutionized how so many of you think about
food and how you build a balanced meal without
restricting and a lot of you will ask me okay
Abby how much fiber how much protein how many
grams of fat do I need and that's the thing this
is highly individualized and really will depend on
your unique body but also your goals you know
the beauty of working within a framework like
this is that there aren't exact rules to follow
there aren't exact numbers that you need to be
abiding by if there was like that doesn't even
make sense that's why diets don't necessarily
work because there is no one siiz fits all
model so the beauty of this is that you get
to tweak it based on how your body responds
but generally speaking for me at breakfast
protein is always my number one priority as
you can see I really need to focus on protein
and that is true for a lot of folks I mean we
have ample evidence that having a protein Rich
breakfast first thing really helps to stabilize
hunger hormones and prevent over eating or you
know a ton of Cravings later on throughout the
day so yeah protein is always going to be king
in the satiety hierarchy and is particularly
important if you're trying to lose weight or
manage your weight which obviously I'm not
but I know a lot of you watching may be now
fiber also really important for me especially
me because I have ibsc and basically I always
find that my digestion gets really thrown for a
loop when I travel and that's true for a lot of
folks so I I pay extra attention to getting
in fiber when I'm traveling and then the fat
really helps to contribute the satisfaction with
the satiety Factor it really contributes to that
feeling like M you know I'm done now I can move
on that felt really good so for me especially
breakfast I really focus in on getting all the
components oh but my husband is now calling me
probably an emergency with the children so I'm
going to go deal with that finish my breakfast
and I'll meet you on the flip side okay daily
supplements so one of the things I like to do
not just when I'm traveling but in general is I
put like all my medication and my supplements in
a Pillow Pack a month at a time so that way I only
have to shlep out all my medications and I have to
refill them only once a month and I don't have
to think about it constantly it's such an ordeal
if you have to shlep everything out to to you
know remember everything you're trying to take
at what what time it's not realistic so if you
are trying to start a supplement regimen and to
stick to it as like a New Year's resolution kind
of situation pill packs save the day it's like
meal prep but for your supplements you know what
I'm saying all right because I put them all in
at one time it's not like I I probably can't even
tell you what's what's in here but I'll give you
a sense of generally what I take in the morning
omega-3 very important in general because most
people do not get enough Omega-3s but especially
important if you have ADHD this is a vitamin D
A I've got a couple probiotics I've got a Spore
forming probiotics and Sacro mcces uh probiotic
of course I've got my um anti- anxiety I've got uh
Chase tree which is for regulating my cycle and um
oil of oregano which is something I take every
day twice a day um as kind of like a maintenance
to prevent uh sibo reoccurrence it's for my I
yes so that's kind of what I take generally in
the day for in morning time so yeah that's my
supplement regimen Please Do Not Duplicate this
this is not for anybody else but for me based
on extensive research knowing my exact needs
lots of blood work knowing and understanding how
nutrition impacts all of my different diagnoses
so definitely work with a register dietition
if you're trying to determine uh a supplement
regimen for yourself big disclaimer there okay
folks delivery time here let me tell you about
my sponsor Thrive market so this time of year is
very challenging for a lot of people because you
know we're extra motivated to eat well and take
care of our bodies but the price of groceries
right now is kind of insane but if you haven't
heard about Thrive Market get excited because
it has really changed the game for me Thrive
Market is an amazing online membership based
grocery store that aims to make Health focused
Specialty Products more affordable and accessible
to everyone they're a One-Stop shop shop offering
foods and snacks eco-friendly kitchen and cleaning
supplies Beauty items supplements HomeGoods and
everything in between most of the year I live in
Canada but as soon as I get here to the states
I order my Thrive box because there are just so
many amazing products that you really cannot get
anywhere else basically you can filter by over
90 different diets Lifestyles and values like
vegan fair trade gluten-free and more they have
an amazing selection of sustainable Seafood
wine and nutritious snacks that my kids adore
and every time I order I discover a new handful of
delicious products that really just become Staples
for us and the best part is all of the items are
less expensive than traditional retail they price
match and members make back their annual $60
membership in savings and for whatever reason
you don't Thrive will credit you the difference I
also love their commitment to sustainability not
only a shipping on orders over $49 free but
everything is delivered with carbon neutral
shipping and from their zero waste warehouses
another thing I really love about Thrive is
that for every paid annual membership the Thrive
gives initiative gives away a free membership to
a lowincome family teacher Andor veteran there's
really so many reasons to feel good about ordering
from Thrive so if you want to save some money on
really unique healthy products this year check
out the link in my description Thrive market.com
slabby sharp to get 30% off of your first order
and a free gift worth up to $60 okay so I know
I'm supposed to be on holiday right now but this
is going to be one of the most chaotic months of
my entire career I am weeks away of the pre-launch
of something that I hope you guys know about
by now and if you don't it's probably because
I've hit my 10,000th roadblock and I'm about to
murder someone but I will not be bullied [Music]
by also I'm pitching my second book right now
which if you guys don't know if you're new here
if you haven't been around for the last few
years my cookbook the mindful CL cookbook is
celebrating its 5year anniversary which is
crazy that that was 5 years ago and I have
another very exciting Venture that I'm working on
right now I don't think I can talk about it yet
but hopefully very very very soon I don't know all
of this cryptic will make sense soon hopefully if
it doesn't already but meanwhile there is like
so much website copyrighting and approvals and
scripts and content planning honestly I need
a clone I asked for one for Chris mup but I
did not get it it was disappointing to say the
least let's get to it okay so one of the things
I've learned um over the past few months about
my ADHD is that I really need to take frequent
movement breaks throughout the day if I want
to be able to like work and be efficient with
my work so I thought I'd kind of go for a little
walk down the street picked myself up some lunch
I could have made lunch myself obviously but a
as we've established tired okay and I've got too
many things to do I'd rather spend this time with
my kids than making myself every single meal in
the day from scratch not to mention I find like
whenever we're traveling most of what's in the
fridge is like breakfast foods and snacks and
foods that are for specific family dinner meals
so typically when we're traveling I will do like
one meal out a day right so whether it's breakfast
lunch dinner we're usually home for dinners we
go out a couple times a week Max but it's harder
with the kids yeah it often becomes too wasteful
to make every single meal from scratch because
I don't have every spice that I need I don't have
every condiment that I need you know it just gets
too wasteful otherwise when you don't have a solid
routine and plan and I was craving me some Greek
salad let's sit down I love the Greek salad from
this place it's that's we've been going to for
years but I love that they have the chickpeas in
in here for plant-based protein plus the chicken
so I kind of have like a double dose double duty
situation going on super satiating and I will eat
anything with feta on it honestly you can give me
a rubber shoe I will eat it if you give me enough
feta one thing I don't love though is all this
styrofoam and plastic like Florida get with the
times you can't even buy a plastic bag back home
in Canada never mind get like every single drink
and take out and plastic and styrofoam it's not
good it's not good that's one thing that kind of
turns me off of ordering in all the time when I'm
traveling but generally speaking I usually try to
get in like a salad a day whether it's like a meal
salad or a side salad especially at lunch because
like I said you know fiber is typically harder
to get in when you're traveling and I'm always
craving fresh crunchy cold salads when it's hot
outside in Florida I don't always have the same
cravings when I'm like at home freezing my buns
off in the Toronto blizzard of a winter but I'm
not going to make you watch me eat this whole
thing I don't know if you're anything like my
husband you probably want to murder me from the
crunching so we will put that on you much later
I crushed that I don't like raw Tomatoes kill me
okay tomatoes and salad gross it's just like slime
and salad please argue with me in the comments
but yeah most tomatoes are not good right if I
get a tomato from if I'm in Italy I'm eating the
tomatoes but yeah here in Canada that said your
girl cannot live on salad alone and while I feel
satiated I'm feeling not 100% satisfied because I
didn't really have any carbs here so I went to my
kids snack stash they seem to like these they're
called yes bars yes please they got nuts dried
fruit seeds spices 3 G of fiber 5 g of plant-fed
protein M that actually really good and just
enough sweetness to really like give me that
sweet end of a meal kind of experiment that
good okay so I got a couple calls I got to
get to I just got a million emails come through
where is hitting the fan so if you don't know
what projects I'm talking about by the time
this video goes live it's because we've hit
another big roadblock but yeah I'm going to
go see the kiddos in a few hours so I really
got to get this stuff done but you know the
reason I don't show my kids here is because
I am vehemently against family vlogging or
really sharing any identifying information
about children on the internet without their
consent and as far as I'm concerned a three
and a 5-year-old cannot really consent to being
Instagram influencers it doesn't matter if you
have a 100 followers or 100,000 followers the
internet is not a safe place not to mention my
kids never consented to being part of my content
I have no right to profit off of them like I see
so many family vloggers do I really want them
to build their own online identities when they
are ready to do so not for the whole world to
know everything about them before they even hit
puberty it's gross so yeah it is a hard no for
me but I will humble brag for a minut look at
this my 5-year-old made this all by himself
it's a a 9-year-old Lego project he did it
all by himself in less than you know a couple
hours per day for 2 days I was really hoping
this was going to last our entire vacation
because it's expensive it's like a 900 piece
Lego kit uh but no he just blasted through it
and I can't even read one page of instructions
so you're have no benefit at all move down to
the to I got it okay I'm sorry am I in your
way yeah that's the most you're going to get from
me about my kids until they're ready to have their
own channel which I will definitely discourage
all right it is officially mom o00 I'm going to
go catch up with the kiddos at the beach for a few
before I head back to make [Music] dinner [Music]
all right folks let's make dinner we're going
to do one of like an Abby staple I guess you
could say this is like one of the easiest meals
that I make for my family it's probably also one
of my personal favorites so we're going to do
brace cabbage and apples with barbecue chicken
sausages and with some roasted potatoes this is
my favorite my kids love them my kids call them
Mama potatoes that's apparently what a signature
move they've become look look how cute these
are they're nibblers they call them so sweet all
right let's boil those so I just boil them until
they're fork tender dice them in half or/ quars
and normally I pan fry them with some butter in
a cast iron skillet at home but I don't have one
here so I just throw them onto a baking sheet and
I added a little melted butter and lots of FLIR
toell and I roasted it at 450° freeze until golden
brown normally I might sauté an onion here but
I am working with the bare bone holiday kitchen
situation so I just throw in a head of shredded
cabbage straight into the pot add a little bit of
water finally dice a green apple and add that
in add lots of pepper salt balsamic vinegar
and balsamic glaze and a little maple syrup and I
pop the lid on until it simmers you got to taste
it m oh I forgot got the mustard very
important I usually do like a straight
up grainy Dijon and like lots of it
but I don't have that here so we're
doing oo honey mustard which just went
on the floor behind me nice smells so
good okay so these say keep frozen and you
can just toss it on the grill cuz they're
already cooked which we love but yeah one
link has 13 g of protein amazing and my
picky toddler does love chicken sausages
so hopefully this will be a hit it's windy
today I'm going to miss barbecuing in January
Floridians you got some good weather I'll give
you that okay but random Canadian thought here
please tell me I'm not alone in this but does
anybody else feel like the shape of Florida
looks like a every single time I see a sign
with like the Florida outline on it driving down
the A1A I literally think it's an upside down and
I'm like what are we allowed to shoot on this
highway not shoot on this highway I mean what
is happening here but no it's just Florida anyone
else well the sausages look good this Grill has
seen better days despite how much I try to clean
it okay dinner is served I'm going to ring the
old Dinner Bell what the you can tell that I'm
tired right and get the old kids in here so I'm
going to sign off before they start making their
appearances because # privacy and I'll meet you
after the kids go to bed also I just realized that
I had pre-cooked chicken sausages twice today um
I had the breakfast ones and then I had these but
judging myself for taking cooking shortcuts on my
holiday is literally the last thing I'm going to
do plus I'm super proud of myself for fueling my
body with lots of satiating protein and colorful
fruits and veg let's not be so Harden ourselves I
think this is a great meal all right get unready
with me my skincare routine while I'm away is not
exactly what it is at home I've got a lot more
products including some prescriptions retinol
I don't really use retinol here oh my goodness
let get ready for the most unflattering light
in this bathroom of all time but what I'm
using here is the proven um cleanser they
sponsored one of my videos and so I really got
into using their products and actually they've
been working really great for me so love that
for us I don't have clean face gloth so don't
judge me I'm just going to ruin this towel
with all my makeup if you have sensitive skin
or sensitive eyes I really like this makeup
remover and also it's small so it's easy to
bring with me but it's more like a bomb so it's
like a cream doesn't dry out your eyes or your
skin get ready for raccoon eyes five 4 3 two
one oh yeah that is scary all right Next Step
currently I'm using this Face Serum by naked
and thriving I really like the texture I switch
it up though I mean I get sent so many great
products so basically every few weeks I'm trying
something new so as long as it doesn't cause any
adverse effects I'm just going to go with the
flow go with what they send me really I don't
have to buy a lot what else oh this is my eye
cream Sho everything's my fingers are so greasy
I can barely open up my you got to grease like if
you don't look like a glazed Crispy Cream you're
not doing it right you're not doing it right
and then this is the triple lipid skin sual
Glazer up baby all right I'm time for a snack
okay kids are down for now until somebody has
a nightmare for the millionth time but I've
taken my supplements and my sleep medication
basically the only difference from the morning
till now is I take magnesium before bed and then
I always take my fiber supplement before bed as
well again because I have ibsc really important
for me I got my Essential reading as a Swifty
and I always have a pretty substantial bedtime
snack something that's got protein fiber and
healthy fats AKA my Hunger crushing combo and
that's because I have a really severe history of
insomnia and the last thing I ever want to do is
to wake up in the middle of the night hungry cuz
it really can throw me for a loop and it really
can just like throw off my whole routine and it
can take weeks to get back on track I've got Greek
yogurt here I either do Greek yogurt or C cheese
before bed typically is my protein source with
some uh fiber rich fruit and uh puffins which is
one of my favorite higher fiber cereals and then
I got this snack mix from Thrive as well and it
looks really really yummy so I'm going to check
that out I always like to have um like a shelf
staple snack beside my bed just in case I do get
hungry the worst thing is having to get out of
bed going to the fridge opening up that bright
fridge it really just screws up your circadian
rhythm so yeah it's got like dried fruit in
it super crunchy I was like what does
uniquely crunchy mean these are very
crunchy I guess cuz they're sprouted M Holo
core crunch very cool well on that note guys
that is all that I have for you today I hope
you enjoyed this video if you did be sure to
leave me a comment below and like this
video if you want to see more of these
real life Day in the Life what in days just
a slice of life situations let me know don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time on Na's kitchen
[Music] bye